john tell us what's happening with shake
shack
shake shack is giving out free bitcoin
shake shack is offering rewards in
bitcoin for people who eat at their
restaurants they partnered with cash app
on this so people who use the cash app
debit card can actually get rewards in
bitcoin they get 15 of their purchase
back in the form of bitcoin on any shake
shack purchase made with the cash card
so that's a debit card available for
cash app users um 50
is a lot i think people are pretty
shocked by that but it's also just a way
i think to connect with the younger
demographic and the millennials as like
60 percent of millennials own it so a
little history about shake shack is for
those you that don't know
internationally shake shack is a nyc
based fast casual restaurant specializes
in burgers it's got over 6 000 employees
um they made
four or they made 715 million dollars
last year um which is a 41 increase over
2020 obviously the pandemic probably
hindered a lot of those sales in 2020
and then they have over 350 stores with
62 percent of them being in the united
states so it's a mainly united
states-based restaurant but they have a
bunch of restaurants internationally as
well um and yeah look they they're
testing whether it can reach younger
consumers on cash app and kind of a
combination between moving users over
from cash app and using the credit card
to hey we can go ahead and go to shake
shack and get rewards and literally earn
bitcoin back by eating burgers that's
pretty cool to see we have a quote here
from jay
livingston the chief marketing officer
at shake shack he said you're always
trying to place your bets on those
things that truly will be meaningful and
not waste resources on the ones that
won't i mean every company should be
thinking about it that way if we just
started taking crypto right now at our
kiosk it would have very little adoption
but
through someone like cash app who's been
promoting it you will get
more
people that that want it and that also
want to learn so that's a perfect
example i think like amc you saw they
just rolled out and then said hey you
can buy movie tickets in bitcoin and i
don't think it's all out of adoption
because bitcoin holders are notorious
for holding their bitcoin with their
diamond hands diamond hands and not
actually selling it or giving it to
someone for a good or a service because
they think it's going to appreciate in
value and that's what he's saying he's
like look if you just roll it out at
your store say hey you can pay in
bitcoin it's good and it will maybe
garner some uh
some pr and stuff and some press in the
news but people aren't actually going to
use it so why are you going to spend
your time doing it it's not really worth
the cost of doing it um but yeah he's
talking about perfectly he's like we
want to use cash has been promoting why
don't we just partner with catch up and
have users come to shake shack yeah i'm
not sure how the economics of a deal
like this works right between cash app
and and uh shake shack who pays who or
how how the money kind of gets filtered
through i'm assuming it's kind of uh uh
related right like they both get some
benefit out of it there's obviously a
marketing play also and cash up has a
product that they want people to use
with the debit card and they're using
shake shack as an avenue to give them
money back so uh they're certainly a
part of that that people are doing it
for a monetary benefit or uh or a
company benefit for sure but ultimately
one shake [ __ ] i've been there a while
but it's good uh and 15 back seems like
an awful lot for something like this
right you're not gonna
i mean who knows i don't think you're
gonna eat shay check every single day
one because uh maybe it's more expensive
than what you would do eating at home or
something else but also you'll probably
get tired of it after a little while too
um but again we've seen other places do
this also you mentioned amc uh i know
that there's been a couple other casino
companies that have donated and other
people and then bitcoin rewards credit
cards have become immensely popular
block buy has one venmo cash app all
these other people are doing similar
things when it comes to credit cards so
it's just another way that you can just
continue to stack stats right like
people bitcoiners specifically the
retail traders within bitcoin and the
retail investors what we've seen that
chart it's up and to the right they
continue to buy bitcoin just dollar cost
average every single day non-stop for a
decade now that's literally what has
been happening so if you can do this
through other avenues through your
traditional spending rather than just
investing i think that's even better and
companies are smart to do this early for
the same reasons that countries are
smart to adopt bitcoin early because you
get headlines it becomes in the news
people want to come visit your
restaurant they know what you stand for
they know that you are about technology
they know that you want to be innovative
they know that you
are into testing new things and i think
that that's important especially for a
place like shake shack or others right
when you're competing in an ultra
competitive industry anything you can do
to stand out i think is important and
what we're going to continue to see is
companies of all
sectors are going to continue to do this
stuff to make sure that they are at the
forefront of what is happening in in
technology and in the world in general
yeah you just hit it right on the head
um a lot of companies have been doing
this right and it's really garnering
that um that press and like the news and
hey like check us out we're we're hip
we're involved in bitcoin we understand
the technology i don't think really
shake shack understands the technology
no hate shake shack i absolutely love
shake shack so definitely biased in this
but other companies have done this as
well right like well it depends who
you're asking i'm sure uh danny meyer
knows what bitcoin is and understands it
but maybe uh some of the other people
that are uh making decisions coming to
marketing or other things like that
maybe they don't i don't know you know i
think it uh it depends but there's
certainly some people that probably
understand it yeah i agree hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time